yeah welcome to this video the second
game of this the u.s. challenge playing
black now then going for our Queens
Indian setup maybe he's trying for Kings
Indian attack type of play with if all
know okay I'll play a flexible reflects
flexible setup was g6 just double fee
and shattering now okay on day 5 i'd
like to have be five without any hassle
okay
yeah yeah I guess I do one Bishop age 6
okay here maybe get the bishop you know
you should play Bishop f4 I guess hmm it
doesn't it's a bit a bit surprising
I could have taken me to actually yeah I
was really just satisfied with getting
the bishops okay well it oh yeah this
opens the f file but it's not clear that
this is really really doing much I'm
quite solid yarn f72 no no real threat
let's see
yeah it's not so self-evident what I
should do is more than one decent way to
play I can go for b5 d5 various palm
brakes I know d5 looks a bit strange
because it allows ed5 and the clearing
of the stubble porn but at the same time
it weakens the you file but not clear
any maybe I should prepare it see phone
is also a move undermining the deep bone
so that if father gets weak haha this is
this yes prevented
I come to you five know if Ivy cannot
play cannot play you five now g-force
winning material and then this makes
make some sense or should I tape with
the night now that's an interesting
question I think I'll take with the pond
exchanging those nights and white what
has to take there's no other move and
then I can take with the night or with
the pawn Knight takes Knight x85 I don't
like Bishop g5 this is a bit lame eg5
yeah this is okay I'd like to have more
pieces on the board and the knight on c3
is not really really well placed yeah
this really asks for an ID for nye
g-form rookie 2 is not really leading to
much yeah come on let's let's do that
takes pawn takes and so I thought this
is not playable because of ED forum I'm
sorry cd4 of course pink sea de de three
winning the house
yeah the question is should I just take
the pawn or is there something better
taking the point is not bad that's that
much is clear but we are taking here
first the service better ed and then we
should be five yeah eh 60 say there's
also a 4 and rook d8 threatening Bishop
b5
yeah but I can he's taking really no
time him what did I overlooked some
direct technical thing
oh this is getting weird okay I'll just
grab him III is a substantial
substantial threat mmm III now I really
miscounted I thought I vporn up I'm not
now that's bad ok check
hoping hoping for the pin hmm check yeah
this is also a pin let's check check
check yeah good to looks against are the
Queen it's quite good to normally need
to coordinate the rooks this rock only
six is nicely placed it it covers to be
six pawnshop okay this didn't really
help check check check hey that's
increment this is a big difference let's
see my money who do I prepare to improve
here Queenie seven is this alright can
you draw it is three times so this is
stupid it's already three times yellow
black and black really should win here
and yeah that's really stupid to know
that I just need to play precisely I
don't I don't see it at the moment I
rookie for as the real one rookie for
rookie six Ruby four and so on I just I
just need to coordinate the troops
compass on minus two yeah yeah he's
right and we should feel Australia it's
still lost
all right yeah this this wasn't optimal
around him it really should the
computer's not it's not so enthusiastic
that's very surprising I thought white
is just toast here yeah compass on minus
0.6 which is still rather moderate it
wants to play like a plate it's a bit
weird alright thanks for watching